it's great to welcome to the program
today Adrienne Barden who's professor of
philosophy at Wake Forest University and
also author of the book the truth about
denial bias and self-deception in
science politics and religion it's
really great to have you on I appreciate
it
hey David thanks for having me so to
start with denialism how far back does
denialism go as far as we know I mean
we're there early denialists when there
were the you know original theories
about what are humans and what is outer
space and is whether God or simply the
machinations of climate or I mean like
how far back does denialism go in some
way shape or form well well yes all of
the all of the above I would I would
send it back several million years as a
matter of fact so so Homo sapiens
evolved in small groups and going back
further to our ancestors they were in
the same situation and the the it's a
really important adaptive trait if
you're living in a small group to be
able to integrate yourself into the
group's ideological worldview you know
if your group worships Poseidon you
better figure out a way to believe in
Poseidon otherwise you're out for
example right so it's really deep deep
in our evolutionary history that we have
formed this talent for rationalizing
beliefs and our beliefs in order to
integrate with a with a larger worldview
so yes and so then that moves forward
through history all kinds of religious
beliefs obviously that's probably the
the beginning of it all beliefs about
other groups because what our
evolutionary context to us we've evolved
in small groups that were in competition
with other groups so if we hate the
group if you know if our group hates the
group we'll get across the river
I'm gonna find reasons to hate that
group too otherwise I'm not able to
integrate myself into my own group
because we don't we don't survive well
on our own cooperation social
cooperation that's our evolutionary
niche that's that's that's what gives us
our advantage that so early on
there was an evolutionarily advantageous
reason why we were able to sort of
potentially suppress contradictory
information in order to be in line with
with our group does that still hold true
today in the same way I mean is it an
issue of evolutionary advantage at this
point well it's well a lot of things
that in the past were an advantage
aren't necessarily an advantage now but
it's still there it's not deep so deep
in our cognitive makeup that we have we
have these skills we're actually very
very good at adapting our beliefs not
just our behavior but our beliefs to our
situation and you mentioned you know
ignoring evidence or you know picking
out the evidence that you want
rationalizing and what's called
confirmation bias right you ignore the
evidence you don't want and these you
seek out you know evidence or reasons to
believe what you want to believe anyway
and that becomes actually particularly
toxic in our current media environment
where you can go wherever you want to to
get the worldview that that you want to
believe and you get the picture of the
world presented to you in in you know HD
video and described to you the way you
want to hear it and it you know it and
so we have but you know what's called
these no media bubbles that people get
into in addition to things like our
geographic sorting here in the United
States in particular peoples have sorted
themselves very well geographically into
like-minded communities is there any
demographic trends that you see in terms
of denialism and and sort of rejection
of Diskin form of confirmatory evidence
maybe like in terms of age is there a
certain age at which this becomes more
prevalent and if so is is that an
education or a cultural thing or
anything demographically that you've
observed well you'll you'll hear
different theories from different social
scientists about this younger people
have demonstrated a little more
cognitive flexibility and openness older
folks are as you would say you know are
more set in their ways
they're also a little more sensitive to
threat they feel more threatened and
that's a really big factor here if we
also look at the progressive slash
liberal versus conservative ways of
thinking about the world so where
conservatives and conservatives
obviously skew at this point in the u.s.
wider and older obviously conservatives
by definition are what we call system
justify errs they are pro status quo
conservatives are comfortable with the
way things are in terms of the social
and economic order and its hierarchies
and they will they will seek out reasons
to dismiss evidence that there's
something wrong with that order such as
you know systemic inequality and and
younger people are less prone to do that
so it seems like there's an asymmetry
there in the sense that when you talk
about the status quo and you think about
inertia certainly it takes less energy
to maintain the status quo in general
all else being equal then it would to
change the status quo and so there is a
sort of it seems that there would be a
structural advantage to those who are
predisposed to keep things the same
because it's easier to do so in a sense
well the status quo is upheld by all
kinds of systems for example the police
the police are the in any society the
police are the tip of the spear when it
comes to maintaining the social and
economic hierarchy that's what they're
that's when we say law and order that's
what the order part of that means you
know when Trump calls themselves the law
Nixon calls himself the law and order
president don't call myself the law and
order president that's what the order is
the order is maintaining the current
social and economic hierarchy and that
includes obviously systems of systemic
racial bias and and systemic in a
structural economic
inequality I'm interested in climate
change in this context because we could
think about a way in which denying
climate change goes against the known
facts and may be advantageous if you're
part of certain political groups right
so in order to keep the peace as you
suggest with that we may have this
tendency to say hey let's I mean even if
there's information that suggests
climate change is real and it's man-made
I'm gonna stick with my group but over
the long term if it's true what science
says about the climate it's self
destructive to the human race and to the
planet so it seems that there there is a
long term disadvantage when it comes to
the sort of evolutionary aspect of it
how could how should we interpret
climate change denial in this context
David I'm very interested in climate
change denial as I'm glad you bring it
up
the first thing I'd want to stress is
that being a climate science denial list
has nothing to do with being stupid or
being uneducated in fact what we see is
the reverse if you're if you're a
conservative you're more likely to be a
climate science denier if you have
college education you're more likely
when you give people a test not just on
science literacy but climate science
literacy you're more likely to be a
denier if you're conservative that when
you score higher on climate science
literacy test so what is that telling us
that telling us is that we are really
good at rationalizing our own beliefs
the more information we have the more
ammunition we get to rationalize those
beliefs this puts us in a classic a game
theoretical situation I don't know if I
want to get too technical on this but
yeah we're individual decisions about
what's best for them in terms of what
belief systems they want to hold on to
become collectively absolutely
disastrous in the long run so that's
interesting so in other words the the
more information we have maybe not the
more that our beliefs align with what we
would call an empirical reality but the
better we are at
justifying the beliefs that we have well
we have more capacity to rationalize it
doesn't we doesn't mean we have to but
there is a definitely a tendency to do
so I mean we love to think of ourselves
as these purely rational beings and all
our beliefs are based on evidence and
listening to qualified experts but in
practice that's not what happens when
they're when it's beliefs when that when
we were presented with facts that are
threatening to us so our our very sense
of identity is based on the group's that
we you know feel associated with our
like if I said if I said you David David
tell me about yourself right now well
I'm gonna tell I'm gonna make up some
things about you so I say say hey David
tell me about yourself - who are you and
you'd say well like well you know I was
I was born in Rhode Island but I grew up
in Texas my parents immigrated from
Ireland I'm a Methodist I'm a social
conservative but I feel strongly about
the environment and all of those facts
that when you'd be telling all about
yourself all of those things are our
relations you have two other groups and
in in terms of their ideological
worldview that's your identity so when
you're presented with facts that
challenge the the worldviews of the
groups that you associated with it feels
like a personal attack you have an
emotional response and our brains are
totally set up to defend themselves and
we defend ourselves by through rational
lays rationalization confirmation bias
what we call motivated reasoning you
have a conclusion in mind there's no
such thing as climate change and then
you seek out reasons to believe that and
you discount the reasons you're given to
believe that there is climate change
right and once again in our media
environment you can always find what
you're looking for when you're looking
for reasons to rationalize your own
belief system so that gets me to sort of
the last major thing I want to touch on
which is we've now widely read and
researched and and discovered that just
giving people more facts and data is not
very effective at changing minds in fact
they can do the opposite as you say
people can see that as a threat and
further kind of plant their
in where where they are what are the
more effective ways to get people to
reconsider their beliefs and to throw
out just a couple of things the one
debate that I've had with some people
and Nathan J Robinson when when I spoke
to him he felt very strongly that
appealing to people on the basis of
their values and tying that to the
conclusion you want is not a good idea
so for example like appealing to fiscal
conservatives to end the death penalty
on the cost issue when in reality that
may not be the primary reason I might
want to end the death penalty there's
debate over whether that's a good idea
or a bad idea
ballpark for us the best strategies for
effectively getting people to change
their beliefs III agree with that
there's a lot of talk about message
framing basically marketing your message
to your audience frame it in their
values in terms of their values hey
you're a conservative let's talk about
conserving the environment right you're
an evangelical let's talk about caring
for God's creation maybe over the very
long term with a lot of interactions and
if you put that all in the right context
for a long period of time that could
change people's minds a few interactions
along those lines it's like it's like
what was that old king who who took his
sword and tried to stop the the waves
come from coming in right right it
people have this lifetime of cultural
identifications and I and identity that
that are just gonna blow that that kind
of intervention out of the water I would
I would say rather appeal to local
issues that are at local interests right
talk about okay I was just reading about
Miami and the fact that Miami is their
saltwater intrusion into the freshwater
supply a map now everyone in everyone in
Southeast Florida no matter what
political persuasion you are really
cares about having drinking water and
not having flooding right so don't talk
about climate change don't talk about
the evidence for climate change just say
okay we've got a sea water problem in
our freshwater supply what do we do
about that I would start there you know
you talk about you know in
in the in the American West talk of El
drought in an agricultural community
right I would start there that's I'm
afraid that's that's not that doesn't
take you all the way to the kind of
global systemic change that we really
need but that's the beginning there's
things you could do in K through 12
education with regard to science
education that I think would be much
better instead of teaching people
science facts we should we should be
teaching kids scientific method really
focusing on that about curiosity about
debunking claims that are not
well-founded and and educate educate
kids that yeah but that's a generational
thing but the thing about climate change
is that we don't really have time for
that so it's an urgent crisis and and I
I don't have this sort of magic bullet
in terms of a message or send out this
message yeah and we're gonna convert
everybody including those people who are
invested in the status quo so heavily
that they're gonna discount that
evidence automatically it's tough but
certainly I agree that at a systemic
level starting with media literacy and
critical thinking far earlier as well we
are we are kind of it's a long game but
we are sort of better better setting up
society to think think in that way the
book is the truth about denial bias and
self-deception in science politics and
religion we've been speaking with the
book's author Adriene Barden who's
professor of philosophy at Wake Forest
University really appreciate your time
today thanks so much David